I'm guessing you recommend Weebly for websites, right?
Honestly, I don't think it matters.
Some people have asked me this.
I just, whatever you're comfortable with, whatever works,
if you get a WordPress wizard
and you can save a couple bucks, great.
If you're like me and you just like easy, use Weebly.
I know in some of these other groups,
they have their own websites.
My only advice is make sure that one person
doesn't control your entire life that doesn't own you.
But if you know which groups I'm talking about,
I have some sites with some of those builders
because I like to try them out.
So I'm gonna be using Weebly though.
I've made all my money on Weebly,
but you can make money on WordPress, doesn't matter.
But yeah, that's what I use.